Залізниця — це життя.
Це найголовніше.
Знаєте, от дійсно я можу сказати, що моє життя
пов'язане саме із цією вузькоколійкою.
[сигналить локомотив]
Поїзд їде. Чути?
А мама моя працювала провідницею.
Одна із династії Ярмошиків,
які давали життя для цієї Вузької.
Така родинна традиція.
Та навіть і я, маючи диплом юриста,
все-таки пішла й закінчила курси провідників.
Думаю: «А хто його знає?».
Може, так і треба буде мамину дорогу продовжувати.
Я знав, що я буду залізничником.
Мій дід тут їздив машиністом.
Практично ми двоє тут спадкові.
У мене і мама працювала на залізниці,
і дід працював, і батько.
Це династія. Також велика династія.
Він прийшов на роботу 2008 року.
Було два «вбитих» тепловози і йому ще дали третього.
У підсумку він з трьох зробив прекрасний потужний склад.
Це його дітище!
Розповім, що за тепловоз.
Ну... Треба було, Люда, там штани прибрати...
— Нічого, хай будуть.
— Ну хай буде так, так цікавіше, так?
Ну, давайте так.
Так видно, що воно в дворі, ніби не на підприємстві.
Я думаю, на підприємстві
дитячі колготки не висять. [сміється]
Ще будучи майстром з ремонту тепловозів, я пробивав тему:
встановити на тепловоз ЯМЗ-двигун.
Я це зробив.
Він в 2 рази менше бере всього:
дизпаливо, тихий у роботі, не засмічує, не призводить до пожежі,
бо цей ще в комини [нижня частина димаря ]викидав
і після викидів робив пожежі,
спалював посадки... Всіляке бувало.
Ми поставили цей двигун. І він працює в нас.
І ми зекономили, практично, на 50 %.
Волонтери із Польщі, Німеччини, із Санкт-Петербургу,
із Москви приїжджали сюди і його самі робили.
У основі були кияни і львів'яни,
але з ними були і з Донецька... Та з усього світу були.
Вузькоколійний транспорт — дуже дешевий.
Чому? Я наведу простий приклад:
щоб перевезти, наприклад,
вантаж за 100 км будь-яка машина спалить 50 л дизпалива.
Десять тон перевезти.
Але коли ж йде потяг,
грузова тяга якого 200 тонн, наприклад,
він може 100 літрів спалити того ж дизельного палива.
То це в рази вигідніше.
Дуже просто робити дорогу вузькоколійну.
Це рейси і шпали.
Набагато дешевше, ніж робити асфальтовану трасу.
[сигналить локомотив]
Я приходила до наших працівників залізниці і кажу:
«Нам треба працювати, бо її закриють».
«Та, а нас в інше місце переведуть».
Мені хочеться її зберегти, бо я розумію,
що за нею стоїть мінімум 100 сімей.
Ще є люди, які не можуть туди добратися нічим.
А взимку — це все...
Зима — значить туди можна не доїхати нічим.
Практично, вузькоколійку закривали.
Було таке питання, що її взагалі закривали.
І вже 2007 року була вказівка закрити.
І тоді придумали фестиваль, щоб її зробити публічною,
популяризувати, щоб розказати усім, що вона є.
То етнофестиваль «Бурштиновий шлях».
І ви знаєте, це вдала назва. Чому?
Якщо по вузькоколійці проїхати аж до кінця,
ви побачите цю назву.
Ви побачите ями, вибоїни... Все побачите.
Ящички ставте, ей.
І побачите, що по цій дорозі якраз іде бурштиновий шлях.
Які тут гарні краєвиди!
Ну чому бачити їх маємо тільки ми?
Хай всі люди побачать!
Ліс.
Павутиння і на ній оці крапельки роси,
і лоси, море лосів!
От найбільше запам'яталися лосі і лані.
Дуже багато звірів, дуже багато звірів.
Діти з Луганщини приїжджали, з Полтавщини приїжджали.
Знаєте, от коли він тримається за поручні...
Дитина вперше в житті побачила потяг.
Та ще й такого маленького, на якому можна постояти.
Дитинка тримається за поручні,
я її отак обхопила, тримаю ту дитину.
У неї очі світяться, а мені ще більш приємно,
бо я дитині зробила приємне.
З'їжджаються дуже багато. Цього року, наприклад,
приїжджали люди і з Білорусі, і з усієї України.
Приїжджали і співаки, і люди, яким цікаво тут побачити.
Ми обмінюємося досвідом.
І поляки. Усі тут були, і французи...
Та весь світ тут був.
Я хотів залишити історію нашої залізниці вузькоколійної,
щоб колись було комусь показати, що було таке і є.
Бо показувати на картинках — це одне,
а бачити — це зовсім інше!